So it literally rained on Trump's parade over
the weekend.
I totally checked out of news and politics
starting up
like right after we finished the July 3rd
show.
Um, didn't pay attention to anything until
last night when I started preparing for today's
show.
But I did hear from friends that it rained
and it poured, uh, during Donald Trump's,
uh, very absurd, kind of this dictator asked
military parade involving tanks and so many
other things.
But the real hilarity was actually in Donald
Trump's speech where he said lots of things
that just made no sense whatsoever.
A, this is just the funniest, dumbest thing,
which tells us that Donald Trump is ignorant,
not just on the big stuff, relationships between
countries and issues of foreign policy and
trade and economics and social issues and
on and on and on and on.
He's also ignorant just about basic human
timelines in a sense.
Donald Trump and his speech meant to, I guess
be inspiring, called the salute to America
on the 4th of July, mentioned the heroic continental
army taking over yes airports during the revolutionary
war, a for independence from England.
And of course there were no planes or airports
in the 17 hundreds but that I guess doesn't
really matter.
Check this out and the explanation which I'll
play for you later is even funnier.
The continental army suffered a bitter winter
of valley forge, found glory across the waters
of the Delaware and seized victory from Cornwallis
of Yorktown.
Our army, Mandy at it read the ramparts.
It took over the airports.
It did everything it had to do and at Fort
McHenry.
Yeah.
What on earth is this guy talking about airports
in the 17 hundreds I received a really funny
email about this from Gordon.
Gordon said, Dear David, I'm a 325 year old
air traffic controller and I wish to protest
that nobody told me that there was a job for
me at any of the multitudes of airports in
the USA in the 18th century.
In order to make ends meet, I was forced to
drive a tank at the battle of Yorktown whilst
my brethren fruit flew supersonic jet fighters
from the nearby nuclear powered aircraft carrier.
If I had known about these airports, I would
have jumped into my Tesla to get to the ATPCO
recruitment office in Trump tower.
Best wishes, Gordon Bane.
So the, the explanation from the Trump administration
is that the teleprompter was faulty for a
moment.
Now that's funny because that could mean two
different things.
Are they saying that a faulty teleprompter
incorrectly added align about revolutionary
war era airports?
That would be a weird thing.
Like normally when things glitch, they don't
put up coherent language that points to inaccurate
historical assertions.
That would be a weird sort of glitch for a
teleprompter.
The other explanation is the teleprompter
glitched in the sense that Trump had to ad
lib briefly, and what Trump adlibbed was that
there were airports in the revolutionary war.
Another really strange moment was where Trump
was praising American inventors, and he mentioned
the Scottish born Canadian citizen inventor
Alexander Graham Bell.
Check this out.
Our quest for greatness unleashed a culture
of discovery that led Thomas Edison to imagine
his lifebelt Alexander Graham Bell, to create
the telephone, the Wright brothers, to look
to the sky and see the next great frontier.
We're Americans.
Nothing is impossible.
So really strange to talk about how great
Americans are at inventing stuff on the 4th
of July and mention Alexander Graham Bell,
who of course was Scottish and moved to Canada
where he was a citizen when he invented the
telephone.
Again, this did not seem to be a teleprompter
glitch.
It actually seemed to be part of the script
or Donald Trump adlibbing himself, both of
which raised a number of questions, another
embarrassment, and as a reminder, because
so much of this is related to teleprompters
failing or Trump reading strange things from
the teleprompter.
Remember what Donald Trump thought about Barack
Obama's use of a teleprompter.
One Example from 2012 when Donald Trump tweeted,
why does Barack Obama always have to rely
on teleprompter, uh, on teleprompters?
Many other such examples.
Of course, Donald Trump, the guy in the glass
house throwing stones, has teleprompt prompter
reportedly glitching.
And suddenly Trump thinks there were airplanes
and airports in the 17th hundreds.
Here's Donald Trump blaming the teleprompter.
You have a little appreciation.
The media, generally speaking, loved it.
They loved the evening.
We had a lot of rain.
I stood in the rain, the teleprompter went
out, so I had the teleprompter went out and
kept going on and then at the end it just
went out.
It went [inaudible].
So I could have said, ah, and actually right
in the middle of that sentence that went out.
And that's not a good feeling.
This guy is just the funniest.
There's any, despite himself, Trump a, if
it weren't so embarrassing internationally,
day after day after day, he has no fun for,
for a guy with no sense of humor whatsoever.
He is inadvertently funny in ways that he
can't even understand.
A president should not get so confused by
a teleprompter going out that he starts saying
there were airports in the 17 hundreds right?
Is it too much to just expect some basic knowledge
if quote, the prompter went out and Trump
mentioned that the civil war was ultimately
decided by who had the better internet technology,
would we accept that?
Say the teleprompter went out.
Of course, he said the internet technology
at the time determine the winner of the civil
war.
No, we wouldn't accept it.
And this is just
a stupid,